you know I don't know my grandmother was
a terrible cook and and my mother died
when I was very young my father was a
terrible cook so I think you know may I
overcompensated a little bit like
present for the cooking of the things so
I don't know what I don't know what
drove me to to to be a chef exactly but
the kind of Chef that I've become I
think was you know sort of unconsciously
you know inculcated by this connection
to the two line especially to like my
grandmother sense of responsibility
which was huge it was like it was like
she she very much believed in open space
and and in doing everything possible to
preserve it and that meant farming in
the case of where Blue Hill was a min to
preserve that the pastoral you literally
needed to pasture and so you know there
was a responsibility came attached to
the pleasure of the views literally and
I think somehow i have connected that
with food and the idea that you know
have those views in that open space
you've got to eat it so you know it's
it's it's chef and plates you know it's
being a chef and and providing pleasure
by way of a kind of responsibility
that's yes that's pleasurable in and of
itself
I graduated and I was a little bit lost
on what to do and I went out and baked
bread in California for a while and kind
of cooked on the side just earned some
money and I thought eventually maybe I'd
write about I was going to write about a
bunch of things but I ended up just
earning extra money by cooking and that
led one thing led to another and I you
know I was always kind of undecided
until i think i went to france and then
I was really cooking and it was sort of
a light went off I think although wasn't
aha moment you know with one of those
things I just like I'm still questioning
thanks yes we sit here now